The joe rogan experience in Australia though in it like kickboxing,
kickboxing.
I Bula Vinnie says watch his fights.
Amazing.
I'll watch it.
I won't go on.
I'm aware to what Jake,
I don't know.
I just thought this dog isn't that interesting.
He likes what he likes or not.
So you know.
Well that's how,
this is a big thing with a lot of Americans.
You know,
when it comes to like I've tried to show American fight fans,
Moy Moitai even like good buddies of mine.
Like how the fuck can you not like this?
Yeah,
he split up.
But people like it.
He's like,
I used to like watch boxing,
but now I've been watching uh,
like movement specialists,
you know,
I've been doing all that movement and stuff.
I've,
I've started doing it and especially with the guy called dom met and now and
he's a student of Edo Porter and I like watching that and find myself just sat
there watching Manin men swinging around and rings for,
you know what that's called?
It's called mental pause.
Is it ball?
Certain stuff or,
that's definitely,
definitely true.
I worked with done not long buck and some of the stuff he does it.
He's amazing.
Especially for Muy Thai law.
Obviously your hip flexors and stuff like that are working all the time.
Some of the like the different stuff that you're doing.
Obviously I get really tight run heaps and stuff when I'm kicking all the time
and that's some of the stuff that he showed me and we worked with it were
unbelievable.
It felt so much looser.
We love that guy.
Yeah.
Have you ever done any yoga?
No.
I did a hot yoga once and I nearly died.
I don't think,
oh,
I'll do that one again.
Oh,
I should do to be fair,
but I think now that I've found done and all the different stuff that he show
me,
I think not a whole lot of that can replace any,
any sort of yoga it shouldn't be doing because this stuff is is amazing.
Well you,
I think it would be a good compliment to your style.
Cause your style fucking,
yeah.
You're so like tense and powerful that I would think that like maybe that will
open you up a little bit loose.
That stuff that Dan does,
he does it like he's open and using different joints and stuff and putting me in
positions that I'm not used to and three fairy is it is hard,
but after you've done it and you,
after you've done the workout,
join you,
you just feel loose.
He feel amazing.
This is brilliant.
It really,
every Wednesday morning and I don't want to go,
I'll fucking tell you the truth.
I'm driving down that it's an hour away from me and I'm thinking,
fuck this,
and then I get there and it's just,
it's just a very,
very special illegal is weed in England.
I'm not intuit me,
listen bro,
take two solid hits and then go to yoga class hitch up behind and run back on
myself or I'm telling you it's not familiar to see American.
We get ahold of some of this California shit orbit serious noise,
two hits and then go to a yoga class.
It's like you're on a journey.
You're like,
you get out of their hour and a half late,
it's perfect because an hour and a half into the sweating,
the parts worn off and you'll like it,
come back down and put in the middle of it.
You feel like the world's going to end any second now in the middle of the
class,
like there's no way this can be sustainable.
There's no way I'm not going to survive.
Did the whole way you'd stick about everything that's going on and Tracy get on
with Joe where like a house on fire.
Been One my dad,
I'm not me.
I can't do it.
I don't agree with me.
I love it for Yoga.
This of my favorite things.
Ever take two hits and go to yoga class.
When you stone,
you can't not be on stone quick.
He just like,
Oh shit.
No,
there's no wearing off quick.
Yeah,
caffeine helps a little bit crazy.
I remember Jordan give me a drop of cannabis.
I will be fine.
I like Mel.
He didn't know.
He saw for for about six hours and I couldn't move and I'm thinking I'm dead.
I'm Sam.
I'm Donia countless time.
Last time I was a high at someone,
I add some cannabis oil and I was sat there watching TV and then I was like
fucking hell of those mine.
And then it got the remote control from the TV and this guy was going to La and
I turned him over and it went,
Huh.
To be fucking self.
And then I knew for not,
it's not for you say well it's just one of those things like anything else
you've got to ease into it.
I understand what you said was it's a story.
Yeah,
I'd like that for just relaxation reflection,
you know?
Yeah.
I think it's also great for like pain management and you know,
after you're done training,
everything's sore.
Your shoulders,
your elbows.
When my Mama died,
they both love it.
But I've just never been able to remember.
I tried to drag before phone,
I nearly at the fucking paranoid Toccoa cause he had to go hide you to dig a
little bit.
But those are those type of guys.
I'm all on north India.
I mean,
so yeah.
I'm sure we've every aspect of if approach when you approach Moitai that could
be a real fucking quick stick.
Yeah.